so the first thing I do is add this
little table if you want to put a title
on it
it's about labeling or classifying
angles if you're like ok I'll call it
classifying because that's a nice big
fancy way so this is like the title of
your whole table okay so at the top if
you like now your 3 columns here's what
I'm gonna call it the 3 things we want
to know about the angles are number one
how big is it so science once you know
its size you can give it a name okay and
there are six different kinds of sizes
six different names and that's why
there's going to be seven rows
lastly we just draw a diagram often the
science so that's like you guys know
picture tells a thousand words right so
that would give us a better idea when
you're visually looking good I can
recognize
so here's our table his heart starts now
all of these sizes right there are going
to be in terms of the units for angles
what is the unit that we used for
measuring angles
yeah its degrees good now by the way if
you've got your calculator there and you
go through like the mode and the cell
that kind of thing you'll notice that
degrees are not the only way to measure
ain't in a comma use your word about
different ones but degrees ones we're
going to save it for now they make
things quite easy to sort of divide up
in and compare with each other okay so
the first kind the first size that I'm
going to think of is between zero
degrees and 90 degrees so this is gonna
go first through here okay now what do
we call such a name let me draw one for
you okay this is two arms and
in between right that's the kind of
thing between that and the name is a
cute right
that's a cute angle isn't it now when
you go up from there
if your aim was exactly 90 degrees
exactly 90 degrees okay
we call that a writing okay no what does
that thing look like well you want them
to perpendicular to each other and when
it's exactly perpendicular we don't put
a curvy little sign what do we put oh
yeah then walks like a little square
sort of thing okay now you studied
patent right what's the next size range
that I'm interesting okay so that's
gonna be the one the actual size what I
shoulda said between between 90 and 180
good okay now I already heard the word
its obtuse that's interesting
what's it gonna look like well if you're
picturing this of this on here it's sort
of moving out so I'm gonna get that
that's the kind of angle better to say
boys now just a little side note acute
and obtuse you guys know I love to bear
the names of things where they come from
they both come from my words this one
means sharp and this one means blunt
because you look at them and you like
it's sharp whereas this is in sports
which by the way is why like doctors
like visit what's it like is it an acute
pain or is it like kind of a dull pain
well that's shock okay that's three
angles sweet we've got three more okay
the next one mmm before I knew things
I'm gonna get tiny sex on yeah I'm gonna
go all the way down and read flat so
look like this put a little point in
there which is like way your angle is if
you got all the way across that's 180
degrees exactly a hundred eighty degrees
yeah and you can kind of see it by
putting two right angles next to each
other and you'll get that straight
okay so like you said that's called a
string okay good
now I already had the name but what's
the actual size that we interested for
this it's best we on the train 180 and
180 and 360 that's a reflex angle okay
now what's that thing look like looks
like this it looks like the obtuse angle
but it's actually the other side okay
now the way I remember that this is a
reflex angle is cuz you know how if
you're ever needed to go to the doctor
and they want to check your reflexes
right they make you sit on the table or
whatever and then they tap your knee and
if you've got the right reflexes what
does your leg do it goes woo like that
like which is that what that looks like
isn't it it looks like your knee and
there's your miss your shoe sorry
and there's the rest of money so that's
how I picture that's how I remember that
it's a reflex angle okay alright that
was between 180 360 lost 1 360 degrees
that's how final run what do we cool
this goes all the way around
it's called revolution exactly right
which I've always found kind of strange
because this is what a revolution looks
like right got a point there and the
answer is all the way around but when
people say wow it's revolutionary
usually they mean what's that mean it's
like a big change isn't it like there's
a french revolution or these new nike
shoes a revolutionary something like
that but actually a revolution just
sends you back in the same direction but
you wanted the first place it's like I'm
facing this thing and then you have 360
degrees around and you're still in the
same direction I find that we anyway
they go there's the names ok once you
apply six different kinds of angles and
that's where we see them you can see by
the way 360 degrees why is it 360 why
why is that the number
why not saying nothing I'm like a
hundred we do like decimal stuff okay
yeah it kind of makes things nicer to
divide out there's a there's other
reasons why it's 360 but one of the main
reasons is it's easy to divide up 360
divides by a lot of numbers by one two
three four five six
I don't think there's my 7 I think it's
two by eight nine ten twelve you can
divide 360 degrees into all of these
numbers so if you wanted to buy up a
blade like slices of pie it's really
really useful anyway